Please welcome my friend,
Ted Danson!
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
Ted and I actually know each other
because we made a movie in Alaska during winter
and lived on an ice floe for three months together.
It's called "Big Miracle."
I remember that movie, by the way.
We all got in a kind of people mover.
There were about 10 of us or something that decided to go.
And everyone was very protective of you
and kind of encircling you,
so that we could move through the crowds and all that.
And I remember in my mind going, is this really necessary?
And coming out of the film, you were mobbed by,
half of Alaska showed up.
So anyway.
Well, I mean, it must be like everywhere you go,
I mean, literally it's a pun intended,
everybody knows your name.
Does everyone bring "Cheers" up to you when they see?
'Cause it's always different projects,
but is "Cheers" like the most evergreen?
Well, "Cheers" is the reason why we're here talking.
Everything I've done in my career
(audience applauds)
is because of "Cheers."
But yeah, I'd have to say
walking through an airport
is where I get a sense of where my career is.
You can kind of tell.
(Drew laughs)
Who's coming up to say thank you for such-and-such
or I saw you in such-and-such?
Usually, I get, now I get middle-aged women coming up to me
and saying, (gasps) "My grandmother
and I watched you on 'Cheers.'"
(Ted laughs)
(audience laughs)
It's like, "Oh, wow, good perspective.
Thank you."
(Drew laughs)
(audience laughs)
Well, we both sort of grown up in front
and with everybody, so.
And you and Mary,
your love story inspires me to no end.
You appear like one of those couples
that's like still hot for each other, just so in love,
so funny, best friends.
Do you remember, 'cause you really are couple goals,
you and Mary Steenburgen, do you remember the first moment
that you fell in love with her?
I was such a hot mess right before I met Mary.
We made a film together called "Pontiac Moon."
But both of us came into that film saying to ourselves,
"Well, obviously, I will mess up any relationship I'm in.
Clearly, I'm not relationship material."
And so we weren't looking for...
And our radar wasn't up.
And we became friends and noticed that, while shooting,
if I got to lunch late and I didn't get to sit next to her,
I was a little upset.
Ah.
And then we took a canoe ride.
This was up in Mendocino on the Big River.
And we had this beautiful canoe with an outrigger.
And we went up with some other folks
who dropped away after two or three hours.
And Mary kept wanting to go around the corner
to see what was next.
And we were gone four hours.
And by the time we came back,
I'd say both of us were in love.
Oh, my gosh.
Ah.
(audience applauds)
(upbeat pop music)